so for anyone who's still saying that
the President of the United States
Donald Trump is draining the swamp this
story is for you Rudy Giuliani told the
New Yorker magazine in an interview that
the president is prepared to suppress
any of the results that they find in the
Mahler program I mean let me give you
more details according to The New Yorker
he said this quote the reporter said
quote I asked Giuliani if he thought the
White House would raise objections wrote
Tobin in the profile and this is what
Giuliani Giuliani said he said I'm sure
we will Giuliani responded noting that
it would be the president who would make
the final call this is this is a
technique that Donald Trump and his
administration has mastered sadly to say
they understand that we are in such a
stage of chaos when it comes to the
sitting president and his many many
different controversies that they can
literally put out in advance their plan
to suppress the findings of the Mullah
probe which in any other administration
would be a scandal big enough to end
that administration but because we're
dealing with the person with so much
slime on them that it seems that nothing
can stick that they feel so free and so
cavalier to just put out there to say oh
we're not going you know we have the
option of suppressing the findings now
this is true it's not it's not it's not
inaccurate but it is unethical voxcom
was doing some reporting on this and and
the fact of the matter is that Muller
honestly only has one legal obligation
and that is to submit his findings to
Rod Rosenstein what happens after that
is that the President does have the
ability to say whether or not he won't
wants those findings to come out but
let's think about this this is an
investigation into the President of the
United States and possible collusion
with Russia and so the president using
his
executive powers to suppress the
findings from that which would prevent
him from being potentially impeached has
has a significant ramifications
significant ramifications in terms of
ethics in terms of morality which we
understand the President of the United
States is not concerned with whatsoever
but the fact remains is that this is
setting a precedent that is going to
have to be addressed this is not
something that can continue without it
being addressed but he has the benefit
the president of the United States has
the benefit of Republicans who have
demonstrated that they will walk in
lockstep with the President of the
United States no matter what he does and
so long as they are empowered the
president really cannot be held
accountable
the majority of what's happening is only
our only things that could be addressed
through impeachment and so long as the
President of the United States has a
majority in his and his party he cannot
be he he can feel free to do whatever he
wants without the fear of impeachment
because they are in power that being the
case that lets you know how important
the midterms are if for no other reason
but a check on presidential power and
it's astonishing to me not really what
it is that people conservatives who are
always talking about the president
overreach of presidential power we are
living in one of the most extreme
examples of presidential overreach and
yet they're saying nothing so even if
this incoming Congress does not impeach
the president which they should the fact
of the matter is they will be there as a
counterbalance to hold him accountable
and rein in his power run amok and
that's why the midterms are so important
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 50
minute audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n